notre gouvernement il a pris
l'initiative elle est bonne on peut pas
dire que le grenelle en soi ne sont pas
une bonne mesure mais c'est les actions
qui vont découler du grenelle qui
m'intéresse moi c'est pas la
communication est ce que la
communication les grands de réunion il y
en a il y en a eu
on a des associations qui sont plus près
du terrain qui dénoncent le malaise
les plantes elles sont très souvent pas
prises en considération
donc les femmes s'interrogent souvent
dans les commissariats sont bien
accueillis plainte classée sans suite
pour nous d'y passer matérialiser passer
d'éléments
deuxièmement kantien éloignement du
domicile conjugal
on éloigne souvent la femme et l'homme
reste domicile conjugal si le monde à
l'envers
c'est à l'homme d'être éloigné à la
phase de rester au domicile
je ne peux pas imaginer pourquoi
aujourd'hui un homme qui prétendument
violent resterait au domicile conjugal
puis on éloignerait la femme dans des
conditions qui sont difficiles
troisièmement les peines mais vous avez
vu les peines on années parfois statuer
sur du sursis dans notre pays quand une
femme elle est allée frapper battu donc
pendant des années humilié du sursis
alors qu'on a parfois de la prison ferme
deux pour des gens qui sont sur des
délits de que que je qualifierais
beaucoup plus mineures et je pense par
exemple à des délits financiers
c'est ce qui pour moi sont beaucoup
moins grave d'un que de porter la main
sur une femme
ce qu'il ya comme un malaise global dans
notre pays il faut que ce grenelle
réponde à ça en espagne tu parlais cyril
d'un pays qui avait fait énormément de
progrès et fait chuter le nombre de
féminicide ils ont mis un milliard sur
la table ça c'est pas une question que
d'argent mais l'argent quand même un
moment donné le permet d'avoir des
plateformes d'appels de former des
policiers d'avoir des assistantes
sociales des psychologues d'assurer un
suivi donc de mettre en place des
conditions d'hébergement de tout ça
c'est des moyens les associations sur le
terrain donc aujourd'hui le compte n'y
est pas si 79 millions d'euros par an ce
qui proposait par notre gouvernement de
que si c'est pas possible
alors on nous dit non c'est pas ça c'est
250 millions par à manger non 250
millions c'est le portefeuille global de
l'égalité hommes-femmes c'est pas la
lutte contre les féminicides et et les
femmes battues
donc il faut qu'on mette les moyens il
faut que se donne
objectif il faut qu'on accompagne ces
femmes il faut qu'on libère à la parole
et surtout il faut qu'ils aient des
sanctions des sanctions lourdes des
sanctions exemplaires
ça n'est pas acceptable qu'un homme
aujourd'hui puissent se dire je risque
quoi du sursis si je frappe à ma femme
non manga qui risquent de la prison la
prison ferme
[Applaudissements]